[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
mietri Serien in allen einen schönen
guten Abend Christine ist mit mir im
Studio später mit der Sporthalle 1 habe
zwei tolle Erfolge guten Abend dann
blicken wir jetzt gemeinsam auf die
Themen
was kann man der Ukraine bieten die NATO
ringt mit sich und findet eine wenig
konkrete beitrittsformel Kiew wollte
deutlich mehr
Gewalt in den eigenen vier Wänden immer
mehr Fälle werden registriert meist sind
Frauen die Opfer und ihre Partner oder
Ex-Partner die Täter
zweimal Gold in Paris bei der
para-weltmeisterschaft holen Leon
Schäfer und Jannis Fischer im
entscheidenden Moment das Beste aus sich
heraus
[Musik]
eine Beitrittsperspektive geknüpft an
Bedingungen ohne konkreten Zeitplan das
ist es was die NATO der Ukraine bei
ihrem Gipfel in Vilnius anbietet gegen
einen schnellen Beitritt hatten sich
vorher schon die USA und Deutschland
ausgesprochen beide setzen vorerst
weiter auf Waffenlieferungen Berlin
kündigte ein Paket über mehrere 100
Millionen Euro an das andere große Rede
Thema ist die Aufnahme Schwedens ins
westliche Militärbündnis Florian
berichtet
er bekommt an diesem Tag extra Applaus
der schwedische Ministerpräsident der
bald gleichberechtigt mit am Tisch
sitzen darf nachdem die Türkei gestern
ihre Blockade des schwedischen
nato-beitritts doch noch aufgegeben
hatte
aber alle sollten auch wissen dass auch
wir das Bündnis sicherer machen werden
und zwar auf lange Sicht
Schweden also bald dabei und andere
während sie auf diesen Bus warten wartet
die Ukraine auf ihre NATO Mitgliedschaft
heißt es auf Bussen in Vilnius die
litauischen Gastgeber drängen auf eine
konkrete Einladung an die Ukraine zum
Beitritt doch sowohl die USA als auch
Deutschland sperren sich dagegen setzen
stattdessen auf konkrete Hilfe der
Bundeskanzler verkündet in Vilnius ein
neues Paket an Waffenlieferungen
insgesamt 700 Millionen Euro schwer
jetzt geht es darum dass wir die Ukraine
aktiv unterstützen bei der Verteidigung
ihrer Souveränität und Integrität eine
Einladung an die Ukraine so heißt es am
Ende könne man aber erst aussprechen
wenn die verbündeten sich einig und
Voraussetzungen erfüllt sind dass man
dann irgendwann auf einen Aktionsplan
zum Beitritt verzichten will das
versucht der Generalsekretär später als
großen Fortschritt zu verkaufen
das ist ein großer Schritt nie hat sich
die NATO stärker zu einer Mitgliedschaft
der Ukraine geäußert einer aber ist
verärgert schon vor seiner Landung in
Vilnius bezeichnet der ukrainische
Präsident selenski die Einigung als
absurd am Abend umjubelte Auftritt
mitten in Vilnius die NATO sagte Lenski
werde die Ukraine sicherer machen die
Ukraine die NATO aber auch stärker
ihn ist Rams ist für uns beim NATO
Gipfel Ines die NATO gibt der Ukraine
grundsätzlich eine Beitrittsperspektive
allerdings ohne Zeitplan was ist die
Formel wert
naja der Kompromiss auf den man sich
hier geeinigt hat beinhaltet dass man im
Fall der Ukraine auf den bisher üblichen
sehr langwierigen Beitrittsprozess
verzichtet aber im Gegenzug stellt man
Bedingungen man will eine künftige
mögliche Einladung an die Ukraine nur
aussprechen wenn Sie bestimmte
Voraussetzungen erfüllt die von nun an
in einem jährlichen Rhythmus überprüft
werden sollen da geht es beispielsweise
um den Demokratisierungsprozess in der
Ukraine oder den dortigen Kampf gegen
die Korruption wie lange das alles
dauert völlig unklar auch wenn
nato-chefs doldenberg heute gesagt hat
man hätte nun der Ukraine einen ganz
klaren Weg in die NATO aufgezeigt ich
denke es war einfach der kleinste
gemeinsame Nenner auf den man sich hier
einigen konnte denn die NATO zeigt sich
zerrissen zwischen den baltischen
Staaten und Polen beispielsweise auf der
einen Seite die gerne der Ukraine einen
konkreteren Weg aufgezeigt hätten und
auf der anderen Seite starten wie den
USA oder Deutschland die hier in Vilnius
ganz klar auf die Bremse getreten sind
das Bild der Geschlossenheit dass die
NATO von hier aus vor allem in Richtung
Moskau senden möchte hat also Risse
überhaupt keine Frage auch das zeigt
dieser etwas krampfhafte Kompromiss Ines
hab vielen Dank für deine Einschätzung
nach Venus
russland werde angemessen und zeitnah
auf die nato-aufnahme Schwedens und die
mögliche der Ukraine reagieren so aus
Minister lavroff russischen Beschuss gab
es auch heute wieder dabei wurde eine
Frau in der Region herson getötet
Attacken auf die Hauptstadt wurden nach
ukrainischen Militärangaben abgewehrt
dort geben Sie die Hoffnung auf einen
raschen NATO-Beitritt nicht auf wieder
Bericht von Alexandra Vacano zeigt
über 500 Tage im Krieg hier in Kiew ist
der Wunsch groß nach dem militärischen
Schutz im Bündnis
se wir brauchen dringend eine
Mitgliedschaft in der NATO und wir
wollen zeigen dass wir Ukraine ist wert
sind der NATO beizutreten ich denke
russland hat große Angst vor einer
NATO-Mitgliedschaft der Ukraine aber wir
werden ganz sicher bald dabei sein Herr
selenski wird es arrangieren je früher
desto besser sagen sie auch hier an der
Front im Osten wo sie für ihr Land
kämpfen
die NATO selbst sollte wollen dass die
ukrainische Armee Teil ihres Bündnisses
wird sie haben gesehen was für Menschen
wir sind und wozu wir fähig sind
vor kurzem hätten sie diesen Ort hier
NES kuscheln von den Russen befreit
jetzt halten Sie hier die Stellung
auch umbachmut sollen sie laut Kiew die
russische Armee von wichtigen
Schlüsselpositionen zurückgedrängt haben
der Feind befindet sich in der Falle
schreibt ein Oberkommandierender und die
stellvertretende Verteidigungsministerin
in bachmut halten unsere Verteidiger
seit mehreren Tagen die Eingänge
Ausgänge und Feindbewegungen in der
Stadt unter feuerkontrolle
Erfolgsmeldungen und Trainingsbilder
rechtzeitig zum NATO-Gipfel die Lage für
die Ukraine hat sich verbessert so
Experten es gibt einige Stellen der
Front wo sich die Ukraine sehr gut
herangeschoben haben an die russischen
Hauptlinien wo sie wichtige Hügelketten
im Besitz genommen haben die Ihnen
weitere Angriffe erlauben dann haben Sie
gute Voraussetzungen geschafft
geschaffen die russischen
hauptstellungen an zumindest einer
Stelle auch sogar zu durchbrechen nicht
aufgeben ist die Devise der ukrainischen
Armee weder beim Kämpfen noch beim
hoffen auf einen Beitritt zur NATO
zur Innenpolitik und einer Überraschung
CDU-Chef März glaubt nicht mehr seine
Ziele am besten mit Generalsekretär
Chaya erreichen zu können nach
anderthalb Jahren hätten sich beide
heute einvernehmlich darauf verständlich
die Zusammenarbeit zu beenden als
Nachfolger hat märz den
Bundestagsabgeordneten Carsten Linnemann
nominiert ja jetzt von Winnie Hirscher
er soll der neue werden Carsten
Linnemann 45 Jahre alt stellvertretender
CDU-Chef Linnemann hat viel mit
Friedrich Merz gemeint merkelkritiker
Wirtschaftspolitiker scharfzig der
Generalsekretär hat natürlich auch die
Aufgabe CDU pur zu transportieren sehr
konturiert zu formulieren sehr klar zu
sprechen das sind alles Fähigkeiten die
Carsten Linnemann hat das hat in der
Vergangenheit häufig gezeigt und
deswegen glaube ich einfach dass auch
vor dem Hintergrund der jetzigen
Herausforderungen Kasten den immer Gold
richtig an dieser Stelle ist
Linnemann war schon vor zwei Jahren im
Gespräch als Generalsekretär aber März
entschied sich damals gegen den Mann aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen und für einen aus
Ost Berlin den Sozialpolitiker Mario
Chaya März wollte damit ein Zeichen an
den Liberalen Flügel der Partei senden
aber chaia fand nicht in seine Rolle er
war vielen in der CDU nicht scharf genug
wie zum Beispiel seine Kampagne gegen
das Ampel heizungsprojekt Friedrich Merz
twittert ich habe mir die Entscheidung
einen Wechsel in der Position des
Generalsekretärs der CDU vorzuschlagen
nicht leicht gemacht Mario Chaya und ich
kennen und seit vielen Jahren und ich
schätze ihn daran wird sich auch nach
dieser Entscheidung nichts ändern
Friedrich Merz hat mit seiner
Entscheidung auch die eigenen Reihen
überrascht nicht alle in der
Parteispitze sollen eingebunden gewesen
sein
Theo call in Berlin was hat Friedrich
Merz jetzt zu diesem drastischen Schritt
bewogen
also doch der klaren Ansage von märz ist
die Grünen der Hauptgegner der Union
sein unterfüttert er das jetzt bei der
Wirtschafts- und Energiepolitik die soll
künftig stärker zum politischen
Kampfplatz werden und da gilt für März
jemand wie der wirtschaftsliberale und
konservative Karten Dendemann
offensichtlich als besser geeignet Mario
zaja sollte ja als gebürtige Ost
Berliner eigentlich auch ein Signal in
die neuen Bundesländer sein das blieb
aber ohne erkennbaren Erfolg und jayas
er leise sondern moderates auftreten das
wurde in der CDU auch als zu wenig
Präsident kritisiert Lindemann wird da
künftig kämpferischer und
angriffslustiger auftreten er schreibt
zudem am neuen CDU Grundsatzprogramm
dürfte also in allen Themen politisch
sehr schnell sattelfest sein und er
dürfte den klaren Kampfauftrag haben die
Grünen in der Wirtschaft und
Energiepolitik zu stellen das Problem an
der Personalie könnte die daraus
folgende Verengung sein jetzt gibt es
mit märz und Lindemann mehr vom Gleichen
danke für die Gemüse nach Berlin Theo
Koll
die krankenhausreform sie kommt darauf
haben sich gestern Bund und Länder im
Wesentlichen geeinigt und sie ist ja
nötig weil viele Kliniken in
finanzieller Schieflage sind wie groß
der Handlungsdruck ist das zeigen diese
Zahlen seit Jahren schon schließen in
Deutschland Krankenhäuser waren es im
Jahr 2000 noch gut 2200 Kliniken gegen
deren Zahl kontinuierlich zurück 21
Jahre später gab es nur noch knapp 1900
Kliniken ein Minus von 16 Prozent und
trotz der Reform ist diese Entwicklung
wohl kaum aufzuhalten
das Klinikum Hochsauerland hat bereits
hinter sich was vielen noch bevorsteht
aus ehemals vier Krankenhäusern wurden
Kompetenzzentren für die ganze Region
verteilt auf vier Standorte darunter ein
neues Notfallzentrum hier geht die
Rechnung auf für viele andere Kliniken
aber nicht Energiekosten werden
ausgeglichen bis zum ersten Quartal 24
aber darüber hinaus haben wir natürlich
eine Inflationsrate die nicht abgedeckt
ist und aus beiden Komponenten der
Leistungsentwicklung und den
Preissteigerungen
resultieren deutliche Risiken für viele
viele Krankenhäuser gestern die Einigung
zwischen Bund und Ländern zur
krankenhausreform doch vielen Kliniken
droht ohne sofortige Finanzspritze die
Insolvenz wir gehen davon aus dass
wahrscheinlich ein Viertel der
Krankenhäuser am Ende dieser Reform
nicht mehr bestehen bleibt jetzt könnte
man sagen in einem geordneten
Reformprozess über 10 Jahre ist das
vielleicht sogar eine Zahl die
verkraften kann wir stehen aber nicht
vor einem geordneten
Transformationsprozess sondern vor einem
kalten Krankenhaus sterben
kistenzsicherung
für Gehäuse
Raum doch auch eine Reform mit am Ende
weniger Krankenhäusern gibt es nicht zum
Nulltarif das Zusammenlegen von
Krankenhäusern das Schließen von
Krankenhäusern das kostet alles Geld und
diese Finanzierungsfrage ist komplett
offen
gestiegene Personalkosten hohe Inflation
eine finanzielle Schieflage die noch vor
der Reform manch einer Klinik das Genick
brechen könnte
auch nach dem Ende von Corona ist
Homeoffice noch Bestandteil des Alltags
in Deutschland arbeitet jeder vierte
zumindest gelegentlich von zu Hause laut
Statistischen Bundesamt waren es
vergangenes Jahr
24,2 Prozent der Arbeitnehmer fast
genauso viele wie während der Pandemie
damit hat sich der Homeoffice Anteil
gegenüber dem vor corona-niveau fast
verdoppelt besonders
it Beschäftigte bleiben oft daheim
Gewalt im eigenen Zuhause hat viele
Gesichter und sie geht ob psychisch oder
körperlich zu rund 92% von Männern aus
das aktuelle Lagebild zur häuslichen
Gewalt zeigt die Zahlen steigen in
vielen Bereichen die Leidtragenden sind
Partner Kinder und Familienangehörige
mehr als 240.000
Opfer wurden registriert das ist eine
Anstieg um 8,5% im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
über 65% der Delikte gehen von Partnern
und Ex-Partnern aus an seinem Stern dazu
wie schrecklich und voller Gewalt eine
Beziehung sein kann musste Dunja
Fischbach erleiden wegen Multiple
Sklerose sitzt sie im Rollstuhl drei
Jahre lang hat ihr ehemaliger
Lebensgefährte sie immer wieder
geschlagen und erniedrigt
eingedroschen und ähm er hat mich
aufs Bett geschmissen dass ich mit dem
Hinterkopf alles Kopfteil geknallt bin
Platzwunde hatte Gewalt in der
Partnerschaft mehr als 157
000 Fälle wurden 2022 gemeldet das
entspricht 432 Taten pro Tag eine
Zunahme von 9,4% im Vergleich zum
Vorjahr 80% der Opfer sind Frauen
Gewalt gegen Frauen ist kein
Frauenproblem Gewalt gegen Frauen ist
ein gesamtgesellschaftliches Problem und
das wir uns kümmern müssen notwendig ist
seinen flächendeckendes ein
niedrigschwelliges Unterstützungsangebot
das in der Stadt genauso wie auf dem
Land existiert und deswegen kämpfe ich
dafür die Lücken im Netz der
Frauenhäuser und Beratungsstellen zu
schließen mehr Frauenhäuser mehr Geld
fordern Experten schon lange weil die
Fallzahlen steigen und die Dunkelziffer
wohl enorm ist viele Gewaltopfer haben
zu viel Angst warten zu lange weiß auch
Cleo Walz die Rechtsmedizinerin
appelliert Beweise zu sichern die
Verletzung heilen ja nach einer gewissen
Zeit ab und dann besteht das Problem
dass man wenn man sich nach Jahren zu
einer Anzeige
entscheidet dass dann keine objektiven
Befunde mehr zur Verfügung stehen
Dunja Fischbach hat ihren Ex Partner
angezeigt und die Gewalt aus ihrem Leben
verbannt
Ende der Woche ist es genau zwei Jahre
her dass die gigantische Flut des Ahrtal
und Teile von Nordrhein-Westfalen
heimsuchte der Gesamtschaden immens laut
Rückversicherern 33 Milliarden Euro
versichert war davon nur ein kleiner
Teil er wurde mit 6,7 Milliarden Euro
weitestgehend ausgezahlt
Nordrhein-Westfalen bewilligte zu dem
Anträge in Höhe von 3,1 und
Rheinland-Pfalz in Höhe von 1,6
Milliarden Euro tatsächlich floss bisher
aber weniger Geld auch von der Mainzer
Landesregierung die heute vor Ort war
Anna duda
das Weingut sehr man in Altena verwüste
durch die Flut einen Schaden von 1,2
Millionen Euro hatte Winzer Lukas
Hermann er hat wieder aufgebaut kann
sich mittlerweile auf die Arbeit im
Weinberg konzentrieren doch die
vergangenen zwei Jahre waren zäh die
Region wird von Menschen hier aufgebaut
die Politiker die wohnen hier nicht
sonst wäre vielleicht die ein oder
andere Entscheidung war anders gefallen
die Politik hat uns natürlich sehr
schnell Geld versprochen sie doch
erstmal eine Zahl in Raum geschmissen
die alle besänftigt hat die Zahl das
sind 15 Milliarden Euro für den gesamten
Wiederaufbau in Rheinland-Pfalz also für
privatpersonenunternehmen Kommunen und
die Infrastruktur ausgezahlt von den 15
Milliarden Euro wurden bisher rund 550
Millionen an Privatleute und Unternehmen
es dauert denn wer einen Antrag auf
Wiederaufbau Hilfe stellt bekommt
Abschlagszahlungen keine gesamtzone für
jede Abschlagszahlung muss eine
Handwerkerrechnung vorgelegt werden und
Handwerker sind oft schwer zu bekommen
zudem sind viele mit ihrer Situation
psychisch überfordert
die Opposition kritisiert zu langsam zu
bürokratisch
und wir brauchen ein Sondergebiet Aartal
mit planungsbeschleunigung mit
deutlichen finanzmittelströmen von den
15 Milliarden die der Bund zur Verfügung
gestellt hat ist nur ein Bruchteil bis
heute abgeflossen hier muss die
Landesregierung handeln dass sie die
Landesregierung anders es gebe deutliche
Fortschritte wie Landesregierung hat
bereits viele
Verfahrens Erleichterungen hinbekommen
hier für das Tal es ist kein
Wiederaufbau zurück auf den alten Stand
vor der Flut können wir alle wollen
einen nachhaltigen Wiederaufbau in eine
sichere moderne lebenswerte Zukunft 2
Jahre nach der Flutkatastrophe vieles
haben sie schon geschafft hier in Aathal
doch es bleibt auch noch viel zu tun
erst Hitze dann Blitze im Südwesten
Deutschlands werden in den kommenden
Stunden schwere Unwetter erwartet einen
Vorgeschmack gab es schon in
Baden-Württemberg aus Frankreich zog
eine sogenannte Superzelle heran und
brachte Sturmböen und Starkregen auch
über Teilen des Saarlandes entlüht sich
vor gut einer Stunde eine Gewitterfront
jetzt zum Sport und da gibt es schöne
Nachrichten von den deutschen parastern
das macht richtig Spaß zuzuschauen
zweites Gold bei den Weltmeisterschaften
für die deutschen parallel
Leichtathleten in Paris am Tag nach dem
Triumph von Weitspringer Leon Schäfer
stieß der kleinwüchsige Jannis Fischer
bei seinem WM die Kugel am weitesten
aller Anfang ist Gold bei seiner ersten
WM holt Jannis Fischer gleich den Titel
mit WM-Rekord Elfmeter 43 für den
kleinwüchsigen Kugelstoß aus Singen ich
wusste dass ich dass ich das so weit in
mir stecken aber ich hätte jetzt niemals
gedacht dass ich bei so einem großen
Event diese Weite abrufen kann und ich
kann es ehrlich gar nicht glauben dass
ich jetzt Weltmeister bin am Vorabend
hatte Leon Schäfer seinen WM-Titel
verteidigt mit Weltrekord 7,25 m bei den
einseitig Oberschenkel amputierten
weitspringern der Leverkusen überholt
den Dänen Daniel Wagner mit dem letzten
versucht wollte es nicht unbedingt so
spannend machen wenn ich ehrlich bin ich
hatte schon so den dritten vierten
angepeilt aber es kommt halt auch nicht
so wie man sich das vorstellt nee
brauchst du holte schulde Junge aus den
Niederlanden Alina aus Berlin wird
Fünfter
fast ja fast hätte es auf dem zehnten
Teilstück der Tour de France zum ersten
deutschen Etappen Sieg der diesjährigen
Rundfahrt gereicht aber im Schloss Sport
war der Spanier pellebao letztlich doch
etwas stärker als Georg zimmermann
der Augsburger liegt kurz vor dem Ziel
in Führung kann dem Antritt von Pelle
Bilbao beim Sprint um den tageslig aber
nichts mehr entgegensetzen nach dem
ersten Ruhetag bei der Tour fehlen
Zimmermann nach mehr als 100 km in der
Ausreißergruppe die nötigen Kräfte der
Spanier Bilbao vom Team war ein
viktorius widmet den Sieg seinem
Mannschaftskameraden Gino Mäder aus der
Schweiz der im Juni bei der Tour des
Swiss nach einem schweren Sturz
gestorben war
und noch zum Tennis Wimbledon
Achtelfinale im Doppel dort setzte sich
vor wenigen Minuten das deutsche Davis
Cap Duo Kevin Grabitz Tim Pütz gegen die
mexikanische französische Kombi Gonzalez
Ranger mit 6:43 und 6 zu 3 durch und das
einzige deutsche Frau ist nun noch Laura
Siegemund ebenfalls im Doppel dabei dann
müssen wir wohl die Daumen Dankeschön
Christin wer noch nicht genug hat von
glutexe der könnte sich nach Island
aufmachen schauen Sie mal was da im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes zu bewundern
ist nämlich diese Hitze ein
Naturschauspiel dass der Vulkan fahr
gerade als fjal ich hoffe ihr habt schon
mal liefert über mehrere 100 Meter
entlässte die Erde aus einer Spalte
blutrote Lava das ganze nimmt bizarre
Formen an das ist ja wenn man so will
vergängliche Schönheit die da so
sprudelt und der Erdball der schließt
sich wohl schon wieder
wann die Gewitter bei uns nachlassen und
wie es weitergeht erfahren Sie gleich
von Katja vorne für 21:45 Uhr empfehle
ich Ihnen das heute journal mit Maria
Slomka das war es von uns morgen gerne
wieder für Sie noch einen schönen Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend das wird eine unwetternacht
erstmal gab es ja heute viel
Sonnenschein aber schon am Nachmittag
entwickelte sich das erste Gewitter hier
an der Donau und auch über Frankreich
brodelte es davor wurde es noch mal
richtig heiß mit an die 38 Grad und
jetzt am Abend ziehen die Gewitter über
das Saarland über Rheinland-Pfalz und
Baden-Württemberg weiter ostwärts etwa
bis 22 Uhr und jetzt in der Nacht
erwarten uns heftige Unwetter Orkanböen
mit bis zu 120 km pro Stunde Hagel mit
einer Korngröße von 2 bis 5 cm und stark
Regen mit bis zu 40 Liter pro
Quadratmeter da werden Bäume Umfallen
auch im Westen gibt es Gewitter in der
Nacht die fallen nicht ganz so heftig
aus ziehen über Nordrhein-Westfalen
weiter Richtung Ostseeküste das wird zum
Teil eine tropische Nacht in der die
Temperaturen nicht unter 20°c
Temperaturen bei 20 bis 30 Grad deutlich
angenehmer es gibt morgen anfangs noch
einige Gewitter hier in Vorpommern von
der Nordsee ziehen Regenschauer heran
und es gibt auch Schauer und weiter im
südlichen Brandenburg
nachmittagsbrode ist dann wieder im
Alpenvorland bis zum Freitag beruhigt
sich dann die Lage guten Abend